economía en france 24 me acompaña el
estudio àngel hablando con daniela muy
buena noche bienvenida brasil tuvo en
2020 su peor desempeño económico en 24
años
hola raúl pues es su producto interno
bruto retrocedió 4,1 por ciento en 2020
este es hoy su peor resultado desde que
inició la serie en 1996 podría decirse
que al menos en términos económicos a
brasil le fue mejor que a otros países
de la región como chile colombia o
méxico
recordemos que el gobierno de jair
bolsonaro siempre se opuso al cierre de
la economía una posición que va en
contra de las recomendaciones de los
expertos en salud pública ahora muchos
atribuyen a esas decisiones que la
economía no haya caído más sin embargo
cuando en varios países vecinos están
mermando un poco el número de casos
brasil todavía sigue registrando récords
y más de mil muertes diarias por corona
- así es daniela cambiamos información
porque el senado de méxico aprobó la
polémica reforma energética de qué se
trata esta iniciativa del presidente
andrés manuel lópez obrador lo ha puesto
de pelea con varios o de sectores
ambientalistas
dicen que impulsa el desarrollo de la
energía no renovable el principal cambio
del proyecto es que sin importar el
criterio económico siempre será dará
prioridad de despacho a las plantas
hidroeléctricas y térmicas de la empresa
estatal que es la comisión federal del
estado por encima de las centrales
privadas los inversionistas muchos de
ellos de eeuu han criticado al gobierno
que a su vez se defendió
no queremos este
de expropiar por expropiar textos lo
digo para que él
este nuestros adversarios
que no son los de los enemigos
no
infunden miedo
a los inversionistas vamos al otro lado
del océano daniela en español protestas
de repartidores de comida
paula hay un polémico proyecto de ley
que busca que las plataformas digitales
como globo over eats contraten a los
domiciliarios para brindarles seguridad
social y jurídica este miércoles hubo
protestas en al menos 10 ciudades de
españa por parte de cientos de estos
repartidores que prefieren que esa ley
les dé el derecho a decidir si son
asalariados o trabajadores por cuenta
propia así que son dos bandos
enfrentados con diferentes intereses
estas aplicaciones en pleno auge están
en ese dilema raúl el mes pasado el
máximo tribunal de gran bretaña
dictaminó que los conductores de uber
deberían calificarse como trabajadores y
no como autónomos eterna pelea daniela
unos quieren otros no y un escándalo
familiar en la marca de ropa deportiva
nike y des con la empresa sin su
vicepresidenta se llama en herbert y
ella se ha venido desempeñando hace 25
años no solo como vicepresidenta y
gerente general sino como jefe de la
división para norteamérica de estar
conocida empresa ella dimitió después de
conocerse que su hijo revendidas
zapatillas deportivas exclusivas y que
usó una tarjeta de crédito suya al
parecer para comprar unos 100 mil
dólares en mercancía
su salida fue anunciada por nike y en un
corto comunicado en el que dice que
nombrará su reemplazo en breve demonio
repaso a la historia de la revista
bloomberg businessweek publicó una
información según la cual el joven joe
es propietario de la firma west coast
streetwear que se dedica a comprar
calzado exclusivo de nike y de otras
marcas para después revenderlo por un
precio mayor
esta firma utiliza programas
informáticos que le permiten adquirir
inmediatamente los diseños exclusivos
tras su salida al mercado
adelantándose a otros consumidores y
coleccionistas el joven dice que nunca
recibió información privilegiada por
esto es más un tema de ética raúl así es
daniela indicadores le preguntó por los
indicadores wall street en el cerro en
rojo
arrastrado por el desplome de algunas
tecnológicas las bolsas europeas de
cerrar
dispares de nuevo influenciadas por el
repunte de la rentabilidad de los bonos
de eeuu y en américa latina méxico cerró
su jornada consecutiva por segunda vez
con fuertes ganancias para finalizar que
nos trajo como cifra el día 400 171 mil
millones de euros es el total de fondos
dedicados por el reino unido a la crisis
por el cob y tras anunciar 75 mil
millones de euros este miércoles el plan
económico de este país incluye un alza
de impuestos de sociedades del 19 al 25
por ciento en 2023
bani gracias por toda la información
económica como siempre ustedes continuar
con nosotros buena noche
[Música]